whether they were aged down decades or
given a virtual haircut these are some
more actors who underwent elaborate
digital makeovers for their parts
gal gadot's Wonder Woman has received
her fair share of CGI assistance the
israeli-born actor isn't capable of
deflecting bullets or chucking tanks in
real life so she needs a little help to
make her character a bit more believable
however the biggest job for the effects
Department was to hide the Miracle of
Life during the reshoots for Patty
Jenkins first Wonder Woman film cadut
revealed to Entertainment Weekly that
she was five months pregnant with her
daughter Maya when she was required to
head back to the set for additional
filming due to her growing baby bump the
filmmakers had to find a way to work
around it since a pregnancy wasn't a
part of the storyline so the costume
designers cut a gap in her costume
around the belly area and placed a green
cloth there that allowed the effects
team to manipulate the visuals at a
later stage speaking about the
experience the Dutch said on close up I
looked very much like Wonder Woman on
wide shots I looked very funny like
Wonder Woman pregnant with Kermit the
Frog they cut a big triangle and painted
green and I came to work me and Maya we
came to work together Martin Scorsese
the Irishman is an ambitious film not
only because it has to keep the
audience's attention for almost four
hours but also because it spans five
decades during its run time while an
easier approach might have been to cast
new actors for each specific era of the
story Scorsese wanted his main cast to
be present throughout senior actor and
Irishman star Robert De Niro also made
it abundantly clear that he wasn't going
to wear green dots or motion capture
suits to make it happen according to the
Los Angeles Times
uh I was just doing a job to make some
extra money
Industrial
took on the back on the challenge of
creating new technology to tell the Epic
Story the team created a new camera rig
for Scorsese to use on set which would
pick up the kind of data that would be
transmitted through the tracking dots
normally then they would edit the shots
in granular detail including the frown
and smile lines of characters such as De
Niro's Frank Sheeran however practical
effects played a major part as well wigs
and Prosthetics were utilized to add to
the authenticity
the Star Wars timeline is a lot like
flipping through family photo albums not
everything is in sequential order the
stories jump around from era to era as
filmmakers and showrunners cherry pick
moments in fictional history in which
they will set their tails this creates a
little problem actors are human and
humans age no matter how good the
sunscreen and skin care products they
use are an actor who was 25 3 decades
ago will look significantly older in
modern times solo a Star Wars story
solved this challenge by casting a
younger actor Alden ehrenreich as Han
Solo but the Mandalorian simply had to
have Mark Hamill return as Luke
Skywalker we knew we wanted Mark Hamill
front and center because you can't bring
back Luke Skywalker without Mark Hamill
in an interview with Indie wire
industrial Light and Magic VFX
supervisor Richard Bluff explained how
the team approached de-aging Hamill
while trying to capture the same look as
from Return of the Jedi Hamel appeared
on set in in costume and performed the
required actions but there was a younger
body double Max Lloyd Jones who was
responsible for many of the sequences as
well essentially the VFX crew deep faked
hammel's face onto Lloyd Jones for the
close-up scenes
Toby Maguire knows all about the power
of CGI having starred in the original
Spider-Man trilogy however it isn't his
time as Spidey that gives him a spot on
this list it's his appearance as the
nameless hitchhiker in Terry gilliam's
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas now why
would the hitchhiker of all people in
this film require any type of digital
assistance some may ask well the answer
involves something green but not the
kind that's placed on actors and
backgrounds for VFX no the reason for
this special effect was cold Hard Cash
according to geek Maguire shaved off all
his hair so the production could get the
unique aesthetic for his character and
ended up being called back for reshoots
a while later reportedly Maguire had a
special clause in his contract that
stated he would be paid an extra fifteen
thousand dollars if he needed to shave
his head again the filmmakers decided to
save some cash so they stuck a bald cap
on him and tried to digitally match the
hair with the previous footage most of
us have to pay to get our hair cut but
McGuire was lucky enough to have it the
other way around
Marvel Studios is no stranger to
de-aging actors but making Samuel L
Jackson's Nick Fury look 25 years
younger was a daunting task previously a
digitally edited character would appear
for no more than a few shots but Fury
was a fundamental part of the storyline
who appeared in a good number of scenes
no corners could be cut fortunately
there was no need for new technologies
or inventions as Lola visual effects
felt comfortable enough with the task at
hand Marvel VFX supervisor Christopher
Townsend explained to the rep that the
team looked at films that Jackson
starred in in the 90s like Jurassic Park
to build their digital version of the
younger Fury but I do know that they
referenced
some films that I did from that time so
when I look at it I see you know Danny
Roman's face from negotiator Jack
graceful aging provided an additional
challenge to the team Lola VFX
supervisor Trent Claus elaborated if
you're working with someone like Sam who
really doesn't have a whole lot of
wrinkles you really have to rely on
physiological changes changes in
structure of musculature textures of
skin the way the weight hangs on your
neck and your jaw things over time like
that we've studied for so many years now
Dwayne The Rock Johnson may look like a
character from Street Fighter in the
flesh but he puts a lot of hard work
into looking good on the screen and
being the most electrifying man in
Hollywood however there is a moment in
The Comedy Central Intelligence where
Johnson plays a teenage version of his
character dancing in the nude and not
looking quite as shredded as he is in
the real world no we're not gonna go
this man insulted you and we're not
going to leave until he apologizes so
it's okay and we got a problem here no
no the team behind this transformation
was the celebrated Whata FX the new
zealand-based special effects company
used smart techniques to make this seam
look as authentic as possible and not
too jarring to the viewer according to
wired wetta got popular vine personality
sioni khalifi to dance while they
captured his performance and specific
gestures then they brought in Johnson
and kalepe to do detailed facial scans
with which they were able to match their
expressions and combine multiple
performances into a single character
since El Camino a Breaking Bad movie is
a sequel to Breaking Bad that follows
Jesse Pinkman not many people expected
Bryan cranston's Walter White to appear
considering the fate of his character at
the end of the series however the film
does a good job of exploring the future
and past so Walter indeed makes an
appearance by sitting down with Jesse in
a diner scene while Cranston never had a
problem shaving his head to play Walter
on the series he did have a problem when
El Camino came around he was performing
on Broadway and couldn't take a razor to
his hair the solution seemed easy enough
a bald cap unfortunately it didn't look
as convincing to the filmmakers as they
had hoped for in the end the digital
effects team had to take the digital
brush to Walter's head to fix any issues
with the bald cap per The Hollywood
Reporter for such a simple and
unassuming scene most of it had to be
recreated with visual effects
foreign